allora non inquadrare dietro cristo con
le mutande sopra il maglione
quando vuoi ciao ragazzi
[Musica]
ce l'avevo qui quando vuoi farmi dire
quando vuoi mi dice aspetta e tossisco
già graziamo ha scoraggiato in testa chi
vuol dire io voglio restare così questa
puntata di cucina buttata fra un po ve
lo spiego fra un po ragazzi benvenuti a
una nuova puntata di cucina buttata buon
anno a tutti quanti siamo tutti quanti
molto contenti allora che cosa ho qui
davanti è l'incubo che vi ha
perseguitato in questi giorni di feste
si chiama lasagna tra parentesi questa
qui sta perdendo liquidi perché da come
potete notare è chiaramente un avanzo
ora quest'anno questo 2022 noi vogliamo
dare un messaggio anzi due messaggi
molto importanti il primo è non buttiamo
gli avanzi ogni cosa può essere usata in
maniera sostenibile intelligente il
secondo messaggio e stiamo per otturare
vile venere quindi sì stiamo per
friggere una lasagna per cui che altro
dire quel terzo messaggio quale grazie
graziana mi ha scoraggiato in testa
sigla
[Musica]
per fare lasagna fritta avremmo bisogno
di una lasagna avanzata farina 00 pane
col prurito delle uova passata di
pummarola orrore grattugiato basilisco
agi
e olio extravergine d'oliva
allora ragazzi quello che devo fare è
prendere una lasagna fredda di frigo e
creare delle sorte di mattonelle
collisioni porzioni non troppo grandi ma
così lunga e c'è una clinica o una grata
che faccio scendere giù devo prima
tagliare da verso il cappello prefinito
natale risponde che sempre smetterò di
sembrare un [ __ ] in video mai quando
smetterò di andarci il video allora
adesso fondamentale prendete una
mattonella di lasagna mettiamola nella
farina la impegniamo per bene vedete
andiamo a sigillarla praticamente ok
adesso prendiamo quattro uova in poi la
salute più di più questo al momento cubi
come si dice e
sappiamo come si prese una cosa di
stanza a questo punto andiamo a infilare
della nostra attuale nulla dentro l'uovo
in cui ha bisogno che tu mi seguì al
volo perché poi andiamo al pan grattato
subito adesso subito è scattato subito
come come un professionista fingi per
una volta di essere un professionista io
sento farina al capolino maniera si
emoziona
speriamo che faccia con e graziana
d'arrivo vuoi sapere che cosa è successo
sì sono molto curioso è una storia sono
ancora un po provato oggi sono venuto
con una messa in piega particolare lacci
un indizio cioè io stavo cercando di
dormire a parcometro private scusa in
albergo praticamente un letto
matrimoniale lasciato a lei come un
signore è un altro lettino messo i piedi
di quel letto matrimoniale io termino
del lettino lei nel letto matrimoniale
insieme alla linea autrice
a un certo punto strada da d'annata dal
niger arriva come in apocalypse now la
domanda ma tu sei cambiato con questa
esperienza sempre sono un tono più
chiaro i capelli e sono in tutto liscio
si può avere un piatto
teniamo fanny altri per fortuna che era
piatto
e quindi è passato
[Musica]
poi un altro lato nella mastro
costruttore beh io non credo il problema
prove intensiva e ci abbia già mare come
la felicità altrui ma questa terra che
sia una casa deve vedere lui i suoi
demoni ap il triste a fastweb che
gianmarco cosa ti rende felice
ti prego vieni in attimi camera è una
domanda difficile questa sta prendendo
tempo per trovare qualcosa che lo rende
felice se sì ma ora sta sudando freddo
già morta però sono molto felice è come
nascondere così bene e fa parte del mio
carattere forse perché sono acquario non
è che ne freghi con un po di astrologia
e non vado più sei tu che stai chissà
cosa astrologia anzi sei tu che mi è
chiaro che è una mattonella 20
trattato ce la faccia in realtà sei tu
che mi ha detto come sono me lo ricordo
anzi è il lato infatti mi ha detto tu
sei impedisce di programma
che si è creato
ma questo che ci fa qui nonna salice
[Risate]
un maglione d'italiano e le forno card
si vede delle ragazze è arrivata
graziato per un attimo che in campo
perché è qualcosa da dire con la bocca
però è
rimasto sconvolto come dire torymus
correggessimo è una cosa normale
un'ottima gente non controlli finora si
è scheggiato
avvicinando cosciente e sveglio
ma parole pesanti a parte di un'amica
qui non si tratta martedì la vita per
stoccarlo in diretta
di persone si le donne cacchiamo chance
correggiamo fine grazie al proprio un
altro perché non ha dovuto fare in testa
e ti ho fatto di male che sono io avessi
saputo cioè se voi siete un po cosciente
a de rocchi sotto le coperte
profilata detta questa è la ragazza che
ogni giorno povera graziana fine voglio
spezzare una lancia di graziare i
sentimenti ma non l'ho mai sentita
scoreggia grazie i mesi di dotare da
qualche parte l'area dovrà uscire essere
di notte
il bagaglino
ragazzi
dando in giro delle stime amica
questo sistema si vedono
[Musica]
[Risate]
io quanto avviato l'olio e direi di
partire con la prima
mattonella troppo presto troppo presto
da the power
vado in power per me è una cosa
gravissima se esce buona della mamma
durante la corrosiva nel frenetico
ragazzi mentre frico faccio martina è
una salsetta al volo cosa faccio olio
aglio vestito
sale e zucchero qualcosa non torna vabbè
ma che cosa senti che puzza di bruciato
un primo sbagliato dai tuoi sbagliato
sbagliano tutti o una cosa dovevi fare
una cosa devi fare e ricordati come per
la fratello maggiore di chi vuole bene
non rompe i [ __ ] ma viene da quello
accanto al brutto anatroccolo chi saprà
i 4 qual è quello che non è venuto bene
[Musica]
[Applauso]
scoppia è invece della nonna 6 doppio
genio come è così buona che se le
avessimo un giornale razionale
l'avesse scoraggiato avrei aperto la
bocca
[Risate]
con il pacifico il mio battito combat in
quel caso è buono perché buona non poco
avete però questo era scontato la buon
live io penso che un altra persona degna
di assaggiare che in passato ha solo
apprezzato da culkin bush graziana
questa
mattina ho detto la verità che è un
avanzo che ha fatto mia zia si sa chi se
questa è buona e buona una cosa che non
aveva dato tutto
ma grazie alla comunque veramente ce
l'ha con te sono otto infatti ceramica
si
cela sogna ottima bel canto grazie
e carica oggi a genova giuria
forse anzi america giulia maria
e
finalmente siamo
brave
enrico no non stanno fermi hanno
soggiornato in tante persone ragazzi
sono gli alpini questo video mi
raccomando iscrivetevi a questo canale
ma soprattutto mettete un po le censure
e prima di mettere un pollice in su
esprimete un desiderio per questo 2022
detto ciò ci vediamo domenica prossima
con cucina buttata alle 12 con una
ricetta particolare celebreremo la
nascita di un artista fenomenale con una
voce pazzesca che ha segnato veramente
la storia della musica italiana ma
[Musica]
non sono io
per la storia della musica mondiale
e anche questo ribadisco non sono io ma
fatecelo sapere nei commenti se avete
beccato ci vediamo domenica prossima
ciao ma che cazzo ho detto buon anno dai
arrivò l'anno buon anno
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]